-Welcome back.
-Thank you very much.
-Happy belated birthday.
You just had one.
-Yes, I did.
-All right.
-And, yeah,
now I'm getting to the age
where I don't want
to talk about birthdays.
-Gotcha. Do you feel like you're
getting jaded as you get older?
-I am. Yeah, I am getting
a little bit more jaded.
You know, I don't take things
as serious as I should, I guess.
-Yeah.
-But I've become more jaded,
as far as Hollywood
and working and stuff like that.
-Oh, that's good.
-Yeah, yeah.
That happens
as you become older.
-Yeah, more refined.
-Yeah.
Like, I was doing this TV show.
It's called "No Activity."
It's on CBS streaming,
which it's a great show.
Please, try to watch it
if you get a chance.
[ Laughter ]
Because I have, you know,
child-support payments.
Stuff like that.
[ Laughter ]
But when we were
shooting the show,
we did a scene where
we were downtown in L.A.,
and the scene was supposed to be
me on my back on the ground.
I had just
fallen off of a building.
And so after
I got out of my trailer
and they took me to the set,
and they said,
"You're gonna be
laying on the ground here,"
I went, "Oh, okay, great.
Is this dirt --
Did we put this dirt here?
Is this Hollywood dirt?"
[ Laughter ]
Show biz?
And the crew guy, he was just
like, "Hollywood dirt?"
[ Laughter ]
"What is that?"
I go, "You know, like,
dirt that we have,
that's like clean dirt."
[ Laughter ]
He was like,
"No, this is downtown L.A. dirt.
There's probably rat, you know,
droppings in the dirt
you're getting ready to lay in,
so good luck."
[ Laughter ]
-Your boys are, what, 16 and 18?
-Yeah, yeah.
-And athletes, play basket--
You coached a basketball team
this year?
-Yes.
Well, not this year.
Like, a couple years ago.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-And did you enjoy that?
-I did.
You know, it was weird,
because I don't know if you ever
coached your kids or whatever...
-They're too young.
They're uncoachable.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Well, my kids was actually --
they were coachable.
But it was weird, because
I'd never done it before.
So, like, the very first game --
Like, I did
a practice with them,
sort of taught them
some basketball plays and stuff.
And then, the very first game,
they were playing,
and they were down by
like 2 points.
And I was on the sideline,
and I was going, like,
"Man, their coach should call
time-out or something."
And I was like,
"Oh, wait, that's me.
I'm the coach.
Time-out, time-out!"
[ Laughter ]
But it turned out
to be very fun and --
You know, like, if you're the
parent of one of the players,
you don't want to favor them.
You want to treat them equally.
But my son Julian
was a very good player,
and we played
the championship --
We got to the championship.
And this was at the
Boys and Girls Club, not NBA.
Don't get me wrong.
[ Laughter ]
But there was --
We got to the championship game.
The team showed up to the game,
and they were all sweaty.
And I said,
"What were you guys doing?"
And they said,
"Oh, we were playing basketball
in the alley."
And I'm like,
"No, you're supposed to be
playing basketball now."
[ Laughter ]
"You have a championship game."
Like, the Golden State Warriors,
they don't go and play
the Pistons for an hour..."
[ Laughter ]
"...then they go play game 7."
-Right.
-And so we got into the game,
and they started losing
'cause they were tired.
The other kids were hot, and,
you know, they were winning.
And then, I had to put the kids
who weren't that good in,
which, you know,
that's just how it is.
Some kids aren't that good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so I had to put those guys
in to sort of cover
until the good kids
could get some rest.
And then, I kept my son in,
and then my son got hot.
-Yeah.
-Julian, he stole the ball,
took it down court,
laid it up like Gervin --
You know, like George Gervin,
like, finger-rolled it in.
And I was like, "Okay."
I'm not going to point out
that he's doing better
than everybody else.
I'm like, "Good job, young man,
keep going," you know.
Next time, somebody else steals
the ball, passes it to him.
He can go in for another layup,
but he stops back,
does like a Steph Curry,
goes beyond the 3-point --
boom, 3 points.
Put us up.
I didn't want to be too proud,
but when he came down the court,
this time I was like,
"Yeah, down here, baby.
Down here."
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah.
That's my boy!
That is my boy!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
I could not keep it in.
-That's great.
Nor should you.
-I know.
And then,
when it was all over, we won.
They gave us
these little medals and stuff,
which is like the only award
I've ever won.
[ Laughter ]
Like, a Boys and Girls Club
basketball necklace.
But we got in the car
with my son and he was very --
you know,
he was happy and stuff.
And I just tapped him
on the shoulder and I go,
"You know what?
You won this that game for us.
You did that.
You did that on your own,
and I'm really proud of you."
-I could not do that
without sobbing.
I would've sobbed.
If the day comes that I ever
get to say something that nice,
I would just break down.
-Dude, I was
so proud of those guys,
'cause they played so hard.
And I literally --
I was, like, up all night.
I was so full of adrenaline.
I'm, like, calling people,
"Hey, guess who won
the Boys and Girls Club
basketball...?"
-Like, "Hold on. I'm gonna text
you a picture of my medal."
[ Laughter ]
-And then, I put the medal
around my rearview mirror
in my car, you know.
-That's great.
-And it would just hit
the windshield
'cause it was so heavy.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I don't care.
I'm so happy."
-This is great.
"Schooled" is wonderful.
This is a spin-off
of "The Goldbergs."
-Yeah.
-You play a principal.
-Yes.
-Do you enjoy that?
Is it a role you enjoy?
-I enjoy all roles.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, yes,
I enjoy this one quite a bit.
It's fun to do.
I'm -- You know, I wasn't --
You know --
I've done a lot of --
You know, people know me from
doing "Mean Girls"
and stuff like that,
but this guy is, like,
a little bit different.
He's a little edgier.
-Yeah.
-I don't know where I'm going
with this story.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I want to ask.
We're talking about edgier.
Another role you're known for
is, of course,
on "SNL," the Ladies Man.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-I know you've been thinking
about trying to reboot
the Ladies Man just to see
what life is like for him
in the post-#MeToo era.
-Yeah.
I think
it would be tough for him.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I think he would always
have to retract every statement
that he made, you know?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So he'd be like --
if he meet a woman in a bar
or something, he'd be like,
"Yeah, listen, baby.
I would love to, like, take you
out sometime if that's cool.
But, listen, if you have a man
or something, I don't want to,
you know, step on anybody toes
or anything.
But, yeah, I would really love
to get you back to my place
and make love to you.
But, like, in a very nice
predictable way.
And, of course, you would
have say in our love-making.
You would give me approval, and
then I would make the next step,
so, anyway...
I'd like to buy you a drink,
if that's okay."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think we all
would like to see that.
-Yeah.
-It's always so great
to have you here.
-Thank you, buddy.
-Give it up for Tim Meadows,
everybody.